We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Steve Burrows is a principal at an engineering consulting company called Arup. I'm Steve Burrows, CBE, and I'm a professional engineer.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。史蒂夫·伯罗斯（Steve Burrows）是一家名为奥雅纳（Arup）的工程咨询公司的负责人。我是史蒂夫·伯罗斯，大英帝国官佐勋章（CBE）获得者，我是一名专业工程师。
And when he saw the great pyramid in Egypt for the first time, he reacted pretty much the way I imagine most people were here. When you actually go and see something that's somewhere in the region of 40 stories high that was built 4,000 years ago, you know you just have this incredible wow moment. But then that structural engineer brain kicks in. Every time you look at something you think, first of all, how did they do that?
当他第一次看到埃及的大金字塔时，他的反应和我预想的大多数人一样。当你真正去观看一个大约有40层楼高、建于4000年前的东西时，你会有一种难以置信的惊叹时刻。但随后，结构工程师的大脑就开始运转了。每次你看到什么东西，你首先会想：他们是怎么做到的？
Then I start thinking, how would I do that? In a recent article in Design Intelligence, he took those questions head on, as if a client gave him a brief to build something like the Great Pyramid today. We get these incredible challenges, where you're doing something that's never been done before. So one of the incredible facts for me was that the great pyramid stood as the tallest building in the world, for centuries. And as someone who, in the present day, is hired to engineers seemingly impossible structures,
然后我开始思考：我会怎么做？在《设计智能》（Design Intelligence）最近的一篇文章中，他直接面对了这些问题，就好像客户给了他一个任务，让他今天建造像大金字塔那样的东西。我们面临着这些不可思议的挑战，要做一些以前从未做过的事情。对我来说，一个令人难以置信的事实是，大金字塔在几个世纪里一直是世界上最高的建筑。作为一个在当今受雇设计看似不可能的结构的人，
Steve Rose thinks that the engineers of 2,600 BC really knew what was possible and made most of the major decisions as a present-day engineer would. So some of the things they knew were that if they built on the Giza Plateau, they could put stones that, to a certain pressure, and the ground didn't collapse beneath it. You can look at other pyramids and see the previous mistakes they were made. And they got to know what the ground capacity was, and I think that determined the size of the great pyramid. Because if you're going to build the tallest building in the world, how tall do you want it to be? Do you want it to be a mile?
史蒂夫·伯罗斯认为，公元前2600年的工程师们确实知道什么是可能的，并像现代工程师一样做出了大多数重大决策。他们知道的一些事情是，如果他们在吉萨高原上建造，他们可以放置石头，达到一定的压力，而地基不会在下面坍塌。你可以看看其他的金字塔，看看他们之前犯过的错误。他们了解了地基的承载能力，我认为这决定了大金字塔的规模。因为如果你要建造世界上最高的建筑，你想让它有多高？你想让它有一英里高吗？
Or just a bit taller than the last tallest building? You've got to make a decision. And I think the decision was made for them by the quality of the ground that they were building on. So that was number one. Secondly, they had to build it in the Pharaoh's lifetime. I'm pretty sure that somebody, you know, a contractor said, you know, with the best will in the world, we can only lay this number of stones a day, and I can only assemble this many men. And assembling men seems to be the right wording here because I totally missed
还是只比上一座最高的建筑高一点点？你必须做出决定。我认为这个决定是由他们建造的地基质量决定的。所以这是第一点。其次，他们必须在法老的有生之年内建成。我很确定有人，你知道，一个承包商说，你知道，即使有最好的意愿，我们每天也只能铺设这么多石头，我只能召集这么多人。而且“召集”人似乎是这里合适的措辞，因为我完全忽略了
this historical revision. But the consensus now is that it was a rather privileged, well-treated class of Egyptians that built the pyramids, not slaves. That blew my mind, Cecil B. DeMille is going to be pissed. Twenty thousand men can only lay this many stones a day, and the Pharaoh typically lives thirty-five years, so that many men, times that many stones, that many stones times 35 years means it's going to be this high. So the ground can only hold so much mass without buckling, the workers can only build so much in a Pharaoh's lifetime. And finally the material had to be delivered to the site in time to build the thing.
这种历史修正。但现在的共识是，建造金字塔的是一个相当有特权、待遇良好的埃及阶层，而不是奴隶。这让我大吃一惊，塞西尔·B·德米尔（Cecil B. DeMille）会很生气的。两万人每天只能铺设这么多石头，而法老通常活35岁，所以那么多人，乘以那么多石头，那么多石头乘以35年，意味着它只能有这么高。所以地基在不屈曲的情况下只能承受这么多质量，工人在法老的有生之年只能建造这么多。最后，材料必须及时运送到现场才能建造它。
And I would think, depending where the quarry was relative to the actual site, which was chosen for its known ground bearing capacity, and also height and visibility above Cairo. They also figured out that they could only get so many stones there. They only had so much material of the quality at the quarry. So Steve Bros. thinks that these practical engineering considerations determine the size of the pyramid. It's height, the number of stones, and ultimately, what we all marvel at thousands of years later.
我想，这取决于采石场相对于实际选址的位置，选址是根据其已知的地基承载能力以及在开罗之上的高度和能见度来选择的。他们还发现，他们只能运送这么多石头到那里。他们在采石场只有这么多质量的材料。所以史蒂夫·伯罗斯认为，这些实际的工程考虑决定了金字塔的规模。它的高度、石头的数量，以及最终，我们几千年后所惊叹的一切。
It wasn't so much mystique as just practical necessity. Another practical consideration that led to the pyramid's longevity is material chemistry. There are other ancient buildings that I'm not held up as well as the pyramid. The buildings I saw had lasted thousands of years, and they hadn't all performed perfectly well. So it was pretty clear to me that the Egyptians had a pretty good understanding of the material
与其说是神秘，不如说是实际的必要性。导致金字塔长寿的另一个实际考虑是材料化学。还有其他古代建筑并没有像金字塔那样保存得那么好。我看到的建筑已经存在了几千年，但它们并没有表现得非常完美。所以很明显，埃及人对他们使用的材料有相当好的了解，
they were working with, but it wasn't 100% perfect. For example, the first large mud brick structures that I looked at had massive vertical cracks in them. And it was very clear to me that they were thermal cracks. What had happened is that they were used to building walls. But when a wall turns a corner, that point becomes very stiff. And because the temperature is very hugely between day and night, these materials, these walls, are expanding contract.
但并不是百分之百完美。例如，我看到的第一批大型泥砖结构上有巨大的垂直裂缝。我很清楚那是热裂缝。发生的情况是，他们习惯于建造墙壁。但当墙壁转角时，那个点变得非常坚硬。由于白天和晚上的温差非常大，这些材料，这些墙壁，在膨胀和收缩。
And when it contracts, the masonry will always break next to the stiff point. So every time there was a corner, I found a huge vertical crack, so they clearly didn't understand the thermal performance of mud bricks. And that problem is exacerbated by the fact that they laid these mud bricks on a mortar bed, so they effectively have two materials for building. So they do use mud brick and mortar. And by putting these different materials together, they thermally move at different amounts, and they had cracked.
当它收缩时，砖石总会在坚硬点旁边断裂。所以每次有拐角时，我都会发现巨大的垂直裂缝，所以他们显然不了解泥砖的热性能。而这个问题因为他们把这些泥砖铺在砂浆层上而加剧，所以他们实际上有两种建筑材料。他们确实使用了泥砖和砂浆。通过将这些不同的材料放在一起，它们的热膨胀量不同，所以它们开裂了。
So somebody must have said, well, if we'd only use one material, lay the bricks dry, would they have performed better? And the answer is yes. And the pyramids are exactly that. So there is only one material that's used. That means that the pyramids, they get very hot in the day and very cold at night. But the material throughout the pyramid is consistent.
所以肯定有人说，如果我们只用一种材料，干铺砖块，它们会表现得更好吗？答案是肯定的。而金字塔正是这样。所以只使用了一种材料。这意味着金字塔在白天变得非常热，在晚上变得非常冷。但整个金字塔的材料是一致的。
And so it didn't crack, because they moved together, they effectively breathe. And because they breathe to account for the changes in temperature, they're able to last a long time without cracking and breaking up. So this prompted bros to think about modern buildings, where we put so many materials together all the time. Steel and glass and aluminium and concrete and cementitious materials and plasterboard. And I started walking round modern buildings and looking at where all the cracks were. And every crack is at the joint
所以它没有开裂，因为它们一起移动，它们实际上在呼吸。因为它们通过呼吸来适应温度的变化，所以它们能够长时间保持而不开裂和破碎。这促使伯罗斯思考现代建筑，我们总是把这么多材料放在一起。钢、玻璃、铝、混凝土、水泥材料和石膏板。我开始在现代建筑周围走动，观察所有的裂缝在哪里。每一个裂缝都在不同材料的接缝处，
between different materials. And I started to think maybe we could think about this a little bit more. And if we did, we could actually make buildings last longer just by thinking harder about those joints, which presently we solved by putting, you know, dewy material in the joint to try and take up that thermal movement. But if we just detail them better in the first place, they would last longer.
我开始想，也许我们可以多考虑一下这一点。如果我们这样做，我们实际上可以通过更深入地思考这些接缝来使建筑更持久，目前我们通过在接缝处放置柔性材料来试图吸收这种热运动来解决这个问题。但如果我们一开始就把它们设计得更好，它们会持续更长时间。
And I think, you know, the longer buildings last the more sustainable they are, the longer their life and the less materials we use in the long run. Longevity is probably the most basic route to sustainability and the pyramids are the poster children for longevity. You know there's an old Arab saying, man fears time, time fears the pyramids. In addition to chemistry, adhering to basic principles of physics keeps your building around for millennia with little or no maintenance. A pyramid is a nice, stable shape.
我认为，你知道，建筑持续的时间越长，它们就越可持续，它们的寿命越长，从长远来看我们使用的材料就越少。长寿可能是可持续性最基本的途径，而金字塔是长寿的典范。你知道有一句古老的阿拉伯谚语：人惧怕时间，时间惧怕金字塔。除了化学，遵循物理学的基本原理可以让你的建筑屹立千年，几乎不需要维护。金字塔是一个很好的、稳定的形状。
And I think they will have learned that. But it isn't as simple as the way I was thinking about it. If they had a bucket of sand, and they poured it on the floor, then it actually naturally makes a pyramid shape. So intuitively, they know that that is a stable thing to do. But actually, one of the interesting things is that the gradient of the sides of the pyramid is not determined like sand by its natural angle of repose. You can actually make it whatever you want to make it, but you can see from the prior pyramids, from the step pyramid and the bent pyramid, the pyramids that preceded the great pyramid, that they were sort of going a little bit steeper, but they never really got above 50 degrees, because I think somebody felt that
我想他们一定学到了这一点。但这并不像我想象的那么简单。如果他们有一桶沙子，把它倒在地板上，它实际上自然会形成一个金字塔形状。所以凭直觉，他们知道那是一件稳定的事情。但实际上，有趣的事情之一是，金字塔侧面的坡度并不是像沙子那样由其自然休止角决定的。你实际上可以把它做成任何你想要的形状，但你可以从之前的金字塔，从阶梯金字塔和弯曲金字塔，即大金字塔之前的金字塔中看到，它们有点变得更陡峭，但它们从未真正超过50度，因为我想有人觉得
there's a sort of a maximum angle about which we should never exceed. So again empirically derived knowledge sets the agenda. If you put these things together, how much stone you can get, the bearing pressure that you can put on the ground, and the angle, you know, it determines the height of the building, and I'm pretty sure the simple mathematics and the work between the architect, engineering contractor, gave a practical limit to what could be built. This exercise in using engineering principles to augment the archaeological data may give us an insight into why the great pyramid is both the oldest and the largest pyramid of Giza, because people probably thought it was the limit of everything. It's the biggest bearing capacity. It's as steep as they could go, and it's as many stones as can be laid in a lifetime. You can't do any bigger than that. It's the speed of light if you like for building pyramids.
有一个最大角度是我们永远不应该超过的。所以，经验得出的知识再次设定了议程。如果你把这些东西放在一起，你能得到多少石头，你能施加在地基上的承载压力，以及角度，你知道，它决定了建筑的高度，我很确定简单的数学以及建筑师、工程承包商之间的工作，给出了可以建造什么的实际限制。这种利用工程原理来增加考古数据的练习，可能会让我们深入了解为什么大金字塔既是吉萨最古老也是最大的金字塔，因为人们可能认为它是所有事物的极限。它是最大的承载能力。它尽可能陡峭，而且是毕生能铺设的最多石头。你不能做得比这更大了。如果你愿意的话，这就是建造金字塔的光速。
I know it's no revelation that the pyramids are well designed. I'm not an idiot, but learning about these practical considerations from Steve Bros. just made me appreciate their majesty in a new way. These structures are not otherworldly. You don't need to come up with crazy theories to explain them. They are the product of smart architects and designers and engineers and skilled workers who apply knowledge that was gained over time and passed down over generations. And through that perfectly understandable and repeatable process, they discovered their limit.
我知道金字塔设计得很好并不是什么启示。我不是白痴，但从史蒂夫·伯罗斯那里了解这些实际的考虑，让我以一种新的方式欣赏它们的宏伟。这些结构不是超自然的。你不需要提出疯狂的理论来解释它们。它们是聪明的建筑师、设计师、工程师和熟练工人的产物，他们应用了随着时间推移而获得并代代相传的知识。通过那个完全可以理解和可重复的过程，他们发现了自己的极限。
Don't get me wrong, I don't ever want to see the tallest building we could possibly build, but I might like to see the one designed with enough durability and flexibility to last for 4,000 years. 99% invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to the it's 99%invisible.org. ونسر حيوية ونضعت بفذك لو تنسان ونساك وتريني بنسجفك
别误会我的意思，我不想看到我们可能建造的最高建筑，但我可能想看到一个设计得具有足够耐用性和灵活性，可以持续4000年的建筑。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持，用创造力创造不同。它是旧金山当地公共广播电台KALW-91.7、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问 99%invisible.org。
وشتأل عزاب معك والأدن ويفكر أرجعتني في الوقت الدنيات جيني معاك وردخائم Мецгинема, урдоха и мари. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。